SENATORS.
HE WAS IN GOAL FOR THEIR VICTORY
SUNDAY AGAINST DALLAS AND
BARBASHEV.
AND IVAN BARBASHEV, GOOD STICK
THERE.
NOW A
RIGHT ON AND 72, 2:00 FOR TRIPP
LEDDY AND THE BLUES GET SET UP
THE CAROLINA HURRICANES AS FAR
AS THE AGGRESSIVE LEVEL ON THE
PENALTY KILL.
AGGRESSIVE.
JUST LIKE WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIET,
AND A SAVE AGAIN.
ANOTHER CHANCE, AND A PAD SAVE
THE KRAKEN SUPER AGGRESSIVE O O
AND SCHENN GETS IT.
NOW HERE'S THEN OFF THE
BOARDS, BORGEN TO SHEAHAN WITH
NUMBER 15 COUGH IT IT UP,
BARBASHEV ON IT FOR THE
DONSKOI OFF THE BOARDS TO
CHECKED BY FLEURY.
SCHENN IS IN
HERE'S WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT,
NICK LIDWEST AND THE BALLY
SPORTS APP.
SO GOOD L
NOW ADAM LARSSOCK,
BUT WHAT HAPPENS IS, IT SLOWS IT
DODO JUMP
IN THEIR STEP AFTER THATLUES PO
PLAY TO GET BACK TO WORK.
>> John: THEY'RE ONE FOR THREE
WITH THREE SHOTS.
THEY WIN THE FACE-OFF, O'REILLY
GETS BACKSOUCY,
KEPT IN BY FAULK.
NOW FOR O'REILLY.
BLUESRE BACK AT FULL
STRENGTH, SO THEY'VE KILLED IT
OFF.ALL IS
HAPPENING NOW ALL YEAR S
OFF EBERLE AND BACK OUT AS ENTE.
AT RISK, A LITTLE BIT OF A
TURNOVER THERE BUT THEN PATIENT
THEIR
FOURTH GOAL BORGEN.
AND THEN McCANN WILL TOSS IT
BACK TO
FOURTH LINE RACES IN, VINCE DUNH
BY McCANN OFF A STICK ANDES
OVER.
AND PLAY CONTINUES.
ROBERT THOMAS UP THE ESCAPE WIT
THAT AND NOW GET A CHANCE TO GOE
FOR SPRONG AGAIN, AND THAT
HEAD HUNTING
FOLLOWING THAT ONE.
NO